comment avoir plus de vues et plus
d'abonnés sur l'étude
vous allez voir c'est pas très compliqué
et souvent ça tient à cette chose on va
regarder ça ensemble si de plus en plus
de chaînes hd sur youtube et devient
extrêmement difficile de réussir sur la
jarrie goûts toutes les astuces et les
meilleures techniques pour gagner des
vues désabonner et enfin réussir sur
youtube inspirez-vous à ma chaîne est
activé la clause fort gay aucune
publication
si vous voulez aller plus loin pour eux
sur youtube cliquez sur le lien pour
rejoindre la communauté question du jour
quelles sont vos bonnes pratiques pour
réussir sur youtube pour gagner des vues
et les convertir en abonnés mettez votre
commentaire je suis curieux de voir que
vous mettez en place les quelle action
commune est pour gagner des vues et des
abonnés sur youtube youtube est de plus
en plus concurrentiel certains canaux
comme le gaming comme la beauté comme le
sport sont de plus en plus concurrentiel
et il est très difficile de faire son
trou
rassurez vous il existe des techniques
qui vous permettront de gagner des vues
désabonner et enfin richard sur youtube
mais ça ça pose en quelques secrets
quelques points essentiels le tout
premier c'est la régularité
youtube a besoin d'être nourri il faut
nourrir à la chine d'un contenu
pertinent et d'un contenu régulier
publié au moins deux à trois fois par
semaine si vous voulez voir votre chaîne
croître publier régulièrement mais pas
publier n'importe comment et pour
publier dans votre niche
il faut absolument définir une
thématique sur votre chaîne une voire
deux thématiques ni faut vraiment
qu'elle soit un briquet pour vous
puissiez progresser
c'est primordial d'ailleurs à ce sujet
regardez les vidéos de vos concurrents
ya forcément des chaînes qui vous
plaisent et qui vous ont inspiré pour
partie voir cette thématique
regardez ce qu'ils font regarder quels
sont les vidéos les plus populaires sans
leurs chaînes
regardez les mots clés sur lesquels se
positionne et tout de suite tout va
s'éclairer vous allez comprendre quels
mots clés utilisés pour réussir à vous
positionner alors attention surtout pas
par plagiat ne fait pas la même chose
que inspirez vous en regardez les thèmes
qui marche les nôtres et qui marche et
faites le à votre sauce en apportant
votre originalité
dites vous bien qu'un abonné va arriver
à s'abonner uniquement parce que vous
apportez quelque chose de neuf et parce
que vous avez votre propre façon de
faire avoir des vues c'est bien mais
derrière personne ne s'abonne ça n'a
globalement pas d'intérêt par exemple la
chaîne parle de stratégie youtube mais
aussi de high tech les deux sujets
s'imbriquent parce qu'on pas d'influencé
et de produits d' influence il ya
quelques mois j'ai posté une vidéo pour
parler un petit peu des rumeurs autour
de l'iphone 8 c'est aujourd'hui la vidéo
qui a le plus marché avec plus de 300
millions et comment est ce que j'ai fait
pour référencer tout simplement parce
que j'ai utilisé les mots clés qui
marche qui se sont référencés et qui ont
permis d'être découvert on sait très
bien que toute façon tous cas lié light
est qu apple en particulier alors les
iphones n'en parlons pas c'est une
thématique qui est très porteuse et qui
marche très bien
seulement il ya beaucoup de vidéos qui
vit sur l'iphone 8 et elles sont pas
toutes aussi bien à faire avec la mienne
quand j'ai fait cette vidéo j'ai d'avoir
moins de 1000 abonnés ma chaîne a
vraiment augmenté
trois cent mille bus plein d'abonnés qui
sont venus et tout ça parce que j'ai
appliqué la bonne stratégie
j'ai choisi les bons mots clés bien
écrit mon titre bien écrit ma
description
j'ai travaillé de contenu de cette vidéo
il est très clair que youtube ne m'a pas
référencé immédiatement tu me rappelles
conserver cette vidéo je me suis dit ouh
200 300 vues 400 vu la vidéo ne décolle
pas et je me suis rendu compte au bout
de un mois un mois et demi que ma vidéo
était carrément en train d'exploser
soyez des abonnés arriver soit ils vont
encore augmenter
dix mille buffet pour plus grands
records 10000 20000 30000 quand j'ai
passé les familles cddf 150 mille deux
cent mille deux cent cinquante mille ou
nourri 300000 les juniors en répétant
combien le sera parce que ma vidéo se
référencent première sur plein de termes
recherchés
il faut vous appliquer cette méthode à
vous trouver les thématiques qui
marchent trouver les sujets recherchés
soit libations lorsque vous publiez de
vidéos dites vous bien qu'il faut trois
à quatre mois pour osi des résultats
concrets un peu de patience et vous
allez voir ça va payer
avoir une niche une thématique avoir de
bonnes vidéos c'est bien mais ça ne
suffit pas il est très important d'avoir
une marque un décor ceci permet d'être
reconnaissable parmi tous les autres ça
va être votre identité sur votre
bannière ça va être vos vignes est
d'atteindre toutes les mêmes a forcément
tout la même couleur mais elles doivent
avoir une vraie cohérence autour de
votre marque et quoi votre ligne est
sûre a tout de suite se dire ça y est
cette chaîne sur youtube eur7 youtube a
posté enfin une nouvelle vidéo
je suis tout de suite la boit pas
obtenir votre titre padzone idées à
votre nom
vignes et a parlé d' alien il faut
vraiment penser contenu de marque c'est
très important
de même sur votre décor il faut vraiment
vous pensiez à votre marque
comment vous allez valoriser votre
marque moi par exemple n'embarque est
toujours présente pour la mauricie
j'ai un fond rouge ça apporte de la
chaleur ça apporte une couleur
il faut vraiment avoir quelque chose qui
va être reconnaissable alors ça c'est
pas mal mais on peut faire beaucoup
mieux
d'ailleurs si vous allez vite et je suis
preneur mettez les voies en commentaire
il est extrêmement important que vous
soyez reconnaissable parmi mille ans
pensez-y
réfléchissez à votre mac os x ainsi pas
vraiment ça m'intéresse ans est publié à
la bonne heure pour ça il ya des outils
qui sont très intéressants comme tube
dit d'ailleurs vous mes liens dans la
description aller voir cet outil qu'est
vraiment très pratique et une version
gratuite et une version payante du coût
global manga très très cher et qui par
contre pas vous apporter vraiment des
outils extraordinaires
il vous dira notamment à quelle heure
publié quand votre audience et là ça
vous permettra vraiment optimisé de
plein de petits points qui vous feront
progresser avec le tout si vous allez
aussi pouvoir trouver les bons donc les
analyser la concurrence voir qu'il ya un
volume de recherche
regardez un peu bas à ce que font les
autres pour proposer d'autres mots clés
et vous permettre enfin de réussir très
sympathique de 10 euros comme en moins
utilisé ça m'a vraiment aidé à
progresser
regroupez vos vidéos dans la même
thématique une plaie hills c'est très
intéressant ça permet d'autant plus pour
les personnes qui viennent visiter votre
chaîne de comprendre réellement comment
est structuré votre chaîne et qu'est ce
que vous proposez vous les structures et
vous les mettez sur votre page d'accueil
comme ça il ya une navigation les gens
vont les voir c'est vraiment top
d'ailleurs youtube a rajouté une
fonctionner il ya quelques temps et vous
permettent de rendre une playlist
officiel vous cliquez dessus vous mettez
que cette liste officielle et elle se
référant seront mieux que les autres
listes finir au fond beaucoup de jeunes
youtuber c'est de faire des vidéos parce
qu'ils ont une idée qui leur plaît qui
en passent par la tête et qui trouve
super ils font leurs vidéos et après ils
regardent comment la référence et c'est
la plus mauvaise façon pour faire cette
vidéo il vaut mieux trouver la bonne
idée
le bon mot clé qui va se référencer dans
votre thématique toujours dans votre
thématique ne sortait pas parce que si
vous faites tout et n'importe quoi après
vos visiteurs vos spectateurs vont se
perdre
ils n'interviendront pas il voire pire
isabelle rond et ça ne nuira à votre
chaîne ont trouvé là
bonne thématique le bonbon clé fait une
vidéo dessus peuvent en faire deux trois
quatre cinq différentes en ayant des
affranchis relativement différente et
une fois que vous êtes sûr vous avez la
thématique qui va se faire avec un
volume de recherche vous pouvez bosser
dessus ne fait pas vidéo s'il n'y a pas
de volume de recharge souhaitez vous
faire plaisir mais vous allez passer
beaucoup de temps ci et vous allez déçu
parce que votre vidéo ne va pas manquer
d'ailleurs je vais me faire découvrir
comment trouver les bons mots clés en
regardant cette vidéo
notre astuce qui est très intéressant
écrivez le mot-clé exact qui correspond
à votre recherche
si par exemple votre niche dans la perte
de poids comment du poids rapidement
comment perdre du poids rapidement voulu
recevoir votre très bonne mais pas que
ça c'est la recherche par pertinence
cette cuvée youtube
quand quelqu'un va taper dans la barre
de recherche comment perdre du poids ça
va lui suggérer commentaires de voir
qu'on va perdre du poids rapidement il
faut vous dit vraiment pertinence pour
vous référencer d'ailleurs une fois de
plus je vous invite à vivre tes fiches
qui vous explique comment dire de bons
titres qui vous permettront d'avoir
plein de vues sur youtube
mais bon c'est vraiment à augmenter la
qualité vos vidéos quand vous gagnez vos
vidéos est ce que ça correspond à ce que
vous allez vous regarder sur youtube
heures vous aimez est ce que le contenu
vous proposez est à la hauteur
quelles sont les erreurs quels sont les
points à améliorer un fond une lumière
un son une qualité d'image un rythme
c'est extrêmement important dans le
rythme on vous pardonnera plus
facilement d'avoir un micro qui est
assez moyen voir une image qui est pas
totalement optimisé mais on pardonnera
pas d'avoir un montage chiant excusez
moi s'il n'y a pas vraiment cette
dynamique les gens dedans pas regarder
vont partir vous ne cumulerait pas deux
temps de vue ce qui est aujourd'hui le
plus important sur youtube c'est le
cumul du temps de lui pour être
référencé pour c'est vraiment reims et
du rythme à dire des choses
intéressantes a expliqué ce qui rend
votre vidéo pour que les gens continuent
à regarder tout ça pour gagner du temps
de vue et puis tout pour que les
personnes qui regardent des vidéos
prennent du plaisir à robinho sont en
ligne à l'ifa lente autour d'idées
analytics c'est très simple cliquez sur
le bouton analysé jeu directement en
dessous de votre vidéo et regardez-les
autant de vues cumulés par rapport à
votre temps de vie moyenne bonne chaîne
regardez comment son arrivée
peut-être dessus comment vous avez
découvert des suggestions de la
recherche
est ce que c'est une publication un
extérieur youtube c'est très intéressant
sans permis de comprendre beaucoup de
choses
est ce que votre tenue pelé est ce que
les gens décrochent si oui à quel moment
pour quelles raisons et qu'est ce que
vous pouvez faire pour remédier à ça ça
vous aidera énormément dans votre
progression
ces points là sont essentiels mais il y
en a encore plein d'autres d'ailleurs si
vous voulez pour eric ciotti vous invite
à aller voir cette vidéo vous donnera
les 10 bonnes astuces pour progresser
quand on commence sur youtube
merci d'abord regarder cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner scrive
contenu vous plaît y aura encore plus de
contenu pour vous aider dans votre
progression sur l'étude de bénévoles y
pousse bleus ce contenu vous a aidé par
rapport aux problématiques youtube quant
à moi je remercie et je vous dis à très
bientôt